[Music]
I think it's important before we get
into the contents of this report that
we're all going to break down in the
course of this hour it's very important
to understand something this is sadly a
swamp document now the swamp always
protects the swamp unfortunately and in
reality before we even get started let
me just remind you of something I said
last night the facts in this case are
not in dispute the evidence is
overwhelming and controvert abel hillary
violated the Espionage Act that's a fact
she mishandled she destroyed classified
top-secret special access programming
information it's a fact she deleted
33,000 subpoenaed emails she acid washed
her hard drive with bleach pit so they
couldn't get a fax and she had AIDS
destroy her mobile devices with hammers
also a fact here's another fact
Christiane saucier spent a year in
prison for what six pictures on a cell
phone at a submarine that he was proud
that he worked on he never shared it
with anybody so in terms of severity it
doesn't compare to what we know Hillary
Clinton did now we also know that Comey
and Trump ater Peter struck started
writing her exoneration in early May of
2016 that's a fact they didn't interview
her until July 2nd 2016 and then July
5th
they exonerated her and we know they
pulled the legal definition of gross
negligence they pulled it right out of
the document they pulled out in one of
their earlier writings in this that in
fact foreign intelligence services in
hacked into that bathroom closet all
affect every single American tonight you
should be shocked you should be
disappointed you should be concerned
about what we're learning we're talking
about abuse of power and corruption at
the highest levels of the FBI and how
the FBI was politicized it's all true
and we have a lot of new evidence we'll
share with you tonight and I want to be
very clear at the start I'm not talking
about rank and file FBI guys I'm not
talking about them I predict by the time
this story ends they will end up being
the heroes when they're finally
subpoenaed and allowed to testify and
tell their stories about what they saw
their bosses were doing
and tonight we'll highlight the stark
difference between two investigations
you get the white gloves special
treatment for Hillary Clinton and then
the heavy-handed tactics all in against
Donald Trump it should shock you if you
believe in equal justice under the law
equal application of our laws and our
Constitution now with Hillary Clinton
everyone was given immunity for Donald
Trump it's search warrant subpoenas
breaking down doors at you know 6 a.m.
guns ablaze the hatred of Donald Trump
from the left and the media in this
country knows no bounds there really was
a scheme to protect Hillary Rodham
Clinton from being indicted and smear
and slander then candidate then
president elect Donald Trump and now
president at all costs
the contempt for you the American people
the things that some of these people
said about us you the American people is
repugnant it's appalling it shouldn't
happen in this country now to the report
as I just said its findings confirmed
pretty much everything we have been
telling you here on Hannity for months
and that many in the media have ignored
we have trey Gowdy summed it up very
well he said quote I am alarmed I am
anchored and I'm deeply disappointed by
the Inspector General's findings of
numerous failures by the DOJ and FBI and
investigating potential Espionage Act
violations by the former Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton without further
discussions here is what Gowdy is
talking about first and foremost we
start with disgraced former FBI director
James Comey now President Trump fired
Comey from Mis handling the Clinton's
server investigation among other reasons
he deserved to be fired tonight the
president is vindicated the Inspector
General finds in this report
James commis actions were both
extraordinary and insubordinate his
investigation into Hillary Clinton
deviated from well-established
department policies now this includes
Comey and other FBI agents allowing
Clinton aide and witnesses to the
investigation Cheryl Mills to actually
sit in during Hillary Clinton's FBI
interview an interview that took place
after Comey had already drafted a letter
exonerating Hillary of all charges and
there's more the report also finds that
while investigating
Hillary Clinton for conducting official
government business with a private email
account whoa James Comey was also using
a private email account to conduct
official government business and by the
way call me responded on Twitter writing
quote I respect the DOJ IG office which
is why I urge them to do this review the
conclusions are reasonable even though I
disagree with some people of good faith
can see an unprecedented situation
differently I pray no director faces it
again thanks to IDs people for hard work
let's break this down James Comey the
FBI director went rogue there's no other
conclusion he broke long-standing
department policy literally writing the
exoneration of Hillary Clinton before
ever interviewing her or seventeen other
key witnesses closed up the
investigation and immediately the same
people that hated Trump that we now know
will prove it in more detail the same
people literally begin the investigation
of Donald Trump remember they exonerated
her way back in May interviewed her July
2nd July 5th
she's exonerated and we know people that
committed the very same mestizos Clinton
well they were investigated in many put
in jail that's why Comey was fired and
should be investigated further and
that's not all now we have even more
evidence to show how FBI agents
mishandled the Clinton investigation
let's go back to the IG report agents
involved in the Clinton Foundation
investigation get this they were
instructed to take no overt
investigative steps prior to the
election and the report also confirmed
that while the FBI was tiptoeing around
their favored candidate Hillary Clinton
who they fully thought would win the
election Clinton's private server was
being accessed by foreign actors oh
that's something else that they took out
and remember the FBI Trump aiding
lovebirds struck in Page well they're
back and they're back in a big way
tonight and by the way they're heavily
featured in horowitz's report when you
see this keep in mind Horowitz
unbelievably this is outrageous did not
find that bias impacted the FBI
investigation
I'm sorry mr. Horowitz you're wrong look
at this newly uncovered
text-message the date August 8 2016 page
exclaims Trump's never going to become
president right right and struck
respondents quote no no he's not we'll
stop it we'll stop it
case you're wondering what struck is
talking about he's making a crystal
clear in this tweet from a month earlier
in July at 2016 damn this feels
momentous because this matters the other
one did too meaning the the
investigation into Clinton but that was
to ensure we didn't bleep something up
this matters because this matters so
super glad to be on this voyage with you
from of course truck is talking about
the impending Russia investigation into
the Trump campaign and comparing it to
the Clinton investigation which he tried
so hard not to screw up because it was
his effort to clear Hillary Clinton of
all charges so she could remain a
candidate the favored candidate don't
forget about the insurance policy that
was referenced in previous paid struck
text if in fact Trump won the election
now it's important to also remember that
all of this took place around extreme
levels of anti-trump bias at the highest
levels of FBI some of it should shock
the conscience page calling Trump an
enormous d-bag and that to the list add
that to the list of insults both page
and struck were lobbying against Donald
Trump calling him an idiot a menace a
lonesome human being and so much more
and struck as the guy leading all of
this investigation then the report
concluded about these texts quote not
only indicative of a bias state of mind
but even more seriously implies a
willingness to take official action to
impact the presidential candidates
electoral prospects
yeah that's political Lisa page by the
way called trumpet and as we said before
we won't go back to that and now the IG
found evidence of so much more bias
among FBI officials for example look at
this message from one unnamed agent
quote trump supporters by the way that's
you are all poured of middle class
uneducated lazy POS is we know what that
is that think he will magically grant
them jobs for doing
nothing on October 28 2016 shortly after
commis letter to Congress that announced
the reopening of the Clinton
investigation one unnamed FBI attorney
sent an instant message to a fellow FBI
employee look at this I'm clinging to
small pockets of happiness in the dark
times of the Republic's destruction and
following the election the same FBI
attorney sent an instant message that
said quote I'm numb with a fellow
employee responding I can't stop crying
now prior to the election in September
2016 one FBI agent involved in an
instant message conversation where they
attack president Trump's supporters
their words not mine I don't use it
[ __ ] and by the way that's only the
tip of the iceberg IG is referred five
FBI employees for investigation after
uncovering their extreme political bias
and get this Horowitz's overall
conclusion said no prevailing bias at
the FBI and its actions in the Clinton
and Trump investigations really mr.
Horowitz you don't see that as political
bias
what do you call everything you just
reported it's all political and look at
this the IG report also found that FBI
employees received oh free tickets to
sporting events from who the destroy
Trump media so-called journalists they
went on golf outings with media reps
they were treated to drinks and fooled
by reporters because of everything we
just showed you that report concluded
the Comey page struck and others
severely damaged the reputation of the
FBI and here's what current FBI director
Christopher Rae said about all of these
damning findings take a look or I take
this report very seriously and we accept
its findings and recommendations it's
also important though to note what the
Inspector General did not find this
report did not find any evidence of
political bias or improper
considerations actually impacting the
investigation under review the report
does identify errors
of judgment violations of or even
disregard for policy and decisions that
at the very least with the benefit of
hindsight were not the best choices
we've already started taking the
necessary steps to address those issues
director ray read the document there's
politics all over that document and for
you to say otherwise is not fair to the
American people nor is it fair to all
the good honest hard-working FBI
individuals rank and file that protect
us every day that you did rightly talk
about today a good start
alright director ray well that would be
firing Peter struck why is he still have
a job despite everything you just saw
Peter struck remains on the payroll of
the Federal Bureau of Investigation are
you kidding me and meanwhile the Obama
administration was also featured in the
report
footnote page 89 at reads quote
President Barack Obama he was one of 13
individuals with whom Clinton had direct
contact using her Clinton mail.com
account that information breaks with
Obama's initial claims that he learned
of Clinton's private email from the
media reports what were they protecting
remember they changed that to say Oh a
high-ranking official and the Attorney
General at the time Loretta Lynch she
was also taken a task in the report for
her now infamous tarmac meeting with
Bill Clinton just before they came to a
decision in June of 2016 the report
states quote Lynch's failure to
recognize the appearance problem created
by former President Clinton's visit and
to take action to cut the visit short
was an error in judgment
okay 45 minutes talking about
grandchildren I'll buy that but first
here's how chairman Gowdy and Goodlatte
by the way responded to this entire
report earlier today take a look what a
dark day it is for the FBI and the DOJ
two institutions our country desperately
needs we desperately have to be able to
have confidence in them and this level
of bias and animus not only didn't want
to stop the Trump campaign he wanted to
stop the Trump presidency this is an
epic struck Peter struck the the FBI
agent who is on hill
clintons investigation and arguably the
lead russia investigator not only wanted
to stop his campaign but once he won got
on the motor probe because he wanted to
impeach he this report shows that there
was special treatment given to Hillary
Clinton in the investigation of her case
there are there is not standard
procedures followed in investigating her
and there was special treatment given
there's no doubt that this was not
proper process and the report shows time
and time again how director Comey and
others made mistakes errors in judgment
or deliberate people can draw their own
conclusions but it was improperly
handled let me sum it up Hillary Clinton
committed felonies and she should have
been charged and these people ran
interference for her we have ample
evidence of bias corruption politics
misconduct at the highest levels of the
FBI the DOJ and now the Obama
administration yet won't call this for
what it is mr. Horowitz you can't
conclude the obvious bias impacted some
at the upper echelon of the FBI and
their work and their so-called
investigation why because that would
taint the phony Russia collusion
investigation we cannot have a
two-tiered justice system in the United
States of America one for the Clintons
one for Trump and one for everybody else
3-tiered perhaps and while the findings
of this report are important we must now
demand more this is a first step there's
got to be accountability we've got to
have a better system of government or
the very foundation of our rule of law
in the United States of America is in
jeopardy